what's up guys I saw the announcement
from KC that he has stopped his daily
vlog and so we're going to try to step
up and deliver for all the people that
are super sad and trying to do daily be
actually daily we've got to come up with
different concepts because there's
family time and different things that I
don't normally show we're going to step
up I'm here filming planning the apps
and so I'm getting my hustle on and I
hope you enjoy I don't really think that
you can see everything you do girl
anything is possible maybe a stop of
Boeing maybe I'll stop there
sometimes d-roc forgets I'm actually
running my career in business here
couldn't you and Tyler put some [ __ ]
down here or somewhere that sir says in
LA or something so I can go on my merry
way and make [ __ ] happen unlike
traditional platforms where NBC had a
contract with you know the the stars of
friends and the monetization was shared
there is no loyalty for an influencer to
a platform whether that's vine Instagram
or snapchat and by the way nor should
there be so we have a whole new set of
rules and a whole new world and I think
that that is absolutely impacting the
tension and the and the curious nature
of like how does it play out between
influencers and platforms again will we
get into a world where the youtubes and
the Facebook's and the snapchats look
more like NBC ABC and CBS and they're
signing exclusive deals maybe
I mean if this continues to be a
conversation can Logan Paul sign an
exclusive deal with Instagram and only
live there and and get generate an
upfront you know dollar amount and then
rev-share
maybe I don't know but I definitely know
that the basic friction or perceived
friction
sitsit the same at every platform
because at its highest point it is
coca-cola and Pepsi z' money going to me
and Logan Paul and and Arielle or is it
going to musically snapchat Instagram or
Facebook right I've got a big idea so
this is really weird the way I'm
positioning it to you so stick with me
you've got to keep it to yourself and if
there's anything like tell me what
you're thinking what I think I try to do
is put the best ingredients on the table
and then work with you on being the co
chef's to figure it out do you see where
I'm going listen surprise in the light
you know how influencers all of a sudden
the 60 Minutes thing like it's all of a
sudden like becoming a very real thing
surprising the light is gonna be the
same thing in 2019 just keep that as a
keep that keep that as a seat keep that
as a seed in the back your mind cuz I'm
gonna be a broken record because I'll
win either you'll do stuff and we'll win
together or you won't and in 2019 you'll
be like [ __ ]
good call you know I wish we could show
the real [ __ ] people would be blown away
I think every brand in the 2017
environment has to have a presence
Facebook is television and if you don't
understand that then you're just not
paying attention you're not a
practitioner or you have some other
financial vested interests to not
believe that and the quicker you
understand that more people consume
videos to sell stuff on Facebook and
they do to watch a television commercial
not a television show the sell stuff the
quicker your business will be successful
just filming something for a client
maybe the rock can show a little clip of
it and just do music over it that was
fun just it's a wardrobe check for
planet of the apps it's getting all
Hollywood out in here
and just in LA for the day couple of
meetings go to a big client pitch a
couple of they're busy eating after that
couple phone calls deep in vaynermedia
world you know some organizational
changes some real offense for 2017 I'm
fired up a lot of new business
opportunities and really feeling aligned
with my leadership team and I'm feeling
aligned with you guys in the community
puffing out content 24/7 365
I mean Jesus people didn't even I mean
there was meetings I was in in 2011
where executives didn't even know what
Facebook was even though it was four or
five years old and monstrous not only is
that not happened it went from little to
no knowledge to disrespect in 1314 right
- that doesn't mean anything who cares
that's an afterthought - now there's not
an executive on earth in the marketing
media business world that is willing to
have massive audacity to disrespect this
environment right they may not believe
in it but nobody's pounding in their
chest and peacocking in a boardroom
saying Facebook's gonna be gone in a
year that you know what I mean like like
Sports Illustrated or ESPN should have
built bleacher report right con Conde
should have built refinery29 or pure Wow
right so I'm a big believer Marriott
should have built Airbnb you know I
don't know you know some transportation
company should have created Ober that's
my general thesis of when you're the
leader create an allocation of dollars
to put yourself out of business before
somebody else does
to do what I just said means that the
CEO the board and the other leaders in
every organization have to have worse
numbers for three years because they're
pouring dollars into something that
doesn't return anything and that's not
in their bonus structure a positive
thing so human behavior takes over and
they do appease Wall Street in ninety
day terms don't invest in a future and
they don't care because they're retiring
in four years this is historical what
happens is what happens is we wake up
one day and major media companies that
we grew up with are gone of course it is
because the Wall Street Journal and
Sports Illustrated and USA Today and the
New York Post they killed somebody else
too
and radio and TV will still be around
and people will buy commercials 20 years
from now but they won't pay as much and
it won't be as important nothing dies
nothing dies things just get exposed
like I by the way I have no best in
intro I'll be the first guy that talks
this way about Facebook and snapchat if
I don't think there are a positive I'm
completely agnostic I'll give you
another thing if the New York Times
wants to cut their full-page ad rates by
75% I'll be buying worth the ROI all I
treat is attention it's not the medium
that I'm a romantic about it's the value
of attention to create the action that
I'm most passionate about